where does in this as far as this
history between the united states and
russia and the ukraine
where does george soros fit into all of
this
i don't know
hasn't he
he's funded many ngos
that have been involved in the whole and
the conflict in the ukraine um as well
as media companies
and
you know soros to me is um
is is an
an evil man who
wants to
you know
change the world to to his image
sort of
unified to some degree but he won't be
able to see it because he's so damn old
uh
i mean he you know his history right you
know that he to an extent
he was a young jewish man who cooperated
with the nazis and when he was asked
about whether he has any regrets he said
no
i had to do this to survive right it's a
cold-blooded individual and it's it's
raw power
i thought what he's after is uniting
all of the western world
and it's sort of a collectivist type
system
what rule
uh
russia and even china is playing in this
scheme i don't know
you know you did you did a lot of
homework
well i mean i used to always think you'd
always used to see you know i would hear
people talk about oh george soros is
behind you know when you would see like
the blm marches and stuff like that
you'd hear people talk about you know
george soros is behind this you know
trying to get people to cause violence
and then when i started watching these
documentaries seeing how he actually did
create ngos and fund media
to create dissent
in these other countries like the
ukraine it starts to get
get deep
descent as far as pro-russian
both ways you don't have to create it
it's there i mean historically there
right there's there's a lot of russians
living there
and
and
remember i
i don't know if i told you in this
interview uh the uh the the hatred that
ukrainians have for russians
is based on uh stalin's action
when when he um
uh
when he starved four million ukrainians
to death in the in the 30s
okay
because
in those days ukraine
a lot of ukrainians didn't want to be
part of the soviet union and
particularly
the uh
somewhat wealthy peasants
didn't want to be collectivized
so this is what stalin did you know he
took the grain away from them and and so
the the national conscience of of
ukraine of the ukrainians that consider
themselves as you know part of a
ukrainian nation
uh has this incredible hatred for for
everything russian
that happened to me when i when i was
still a soviet agent and i met some
ukrainians while studying
in college
and i i was blown away by when when we
talked about the soviet union how how
how much hate
came out of them so i had to stay away
from ukrainians
uh
and um where was i going with this and
and there are russians living
in the ukraine so so that conflict
was there before
putin invaded
it's been going on since the soviet
union fell apart
and there are some
nazis still living in ukraine
quite a bit actually right i can i can i
can give you one proof i know i need
only one one piece of information you
know who um
uh
i forgot his first name um
pandara that bandera
was a ukrainian nazi there's like
statues of him right he's steppon
bandera yes okay yes stephan bandera was
born in uh
19
big anti-communist yes and anti-semites
anti-semite and uh he led a bunch of
folk i mean the ukrainian nazis uh were
as murderers even even more so than the
the germans and they they participated
in pogroms and killed jews and all that
bandera was uh
born in
1919
in 2019
the ukrainian government issued a
commemorative stamp to honor stephan
bandera
enough said isn't that when zelensky
zolinski was not yet in power no he
wasn't okay it was not yet but somebody
high level enough thought it was a good
idea to honor
this this nazi
killing machine i mean it's crazy it's
it's
the amount of power some of those those
i don't know what you would call them
nazi militias in the in the ukraine that
are currently there it's like the
equivalent of
it'd be like the equivalent of the kkk
having its own
sort of
military power in the u.s
yeah and so what we're talking about
right now is uh it cannot be found in
united states media uh because because
it's too complicated
i think this this the entire ukraine has
been a hornet's nest for
forever and it would have probably been
a good idea for
the western world not to meddle in this
because it just isolate and
let it play itself out because no good
will come of it but then you see uh you
know what's the incentive for the
western world to meddle in this and what
you do see is you see you know the
stocks of companies like raytheon
going through the roof and then you see
you know people that are in government
investing in those stocks before this
whole thing happens and
yes and uh you know that remember that
president eisenhower a military man
warned of
the power of the military-industrial
complex and that's apparently at work
here you know we
we send a bunch of arms over there they
need to be replaced right
um the arms are are
the money that we give away is taxpayer
money yours and mine
and uh
you know the the
the weapons manufacturers
make more money
yep and
it's very often when people say follow
the money that's ultimately uh
that dictates where people are going
yeah right
well i mean it's hard it's hard to
predict where it's going to go from here
obviously you know
it's it's definitely becomes a lot more
sensitive when we're almost kind of in
another cold war
um
are you are you familiar with i'm sure
you are with us the story of the russian
submarine commander
who was i believe he was off the coast
of cuba right
and it was he was given the command to
strike yes right and he said that we're
misinterpreting this yes what is that
how is
supposed to be three individuals who
have to agree or two out of the three or
no three generally three
but in this case the commander had uh
over override power over the other two
the other two were going uh they voted
yes and he says i'm not doing it
and and this this was officially set up
that way i don't know exactly the
background yes that could have started
world war
iii this one man could have prevented
the nuclear apocalypse that is correct
and we might well be in a similar
situation going forward here it's
frightening yes terrifying yes um well